jerome boateng 25 years old Germany
defender his brother Kevin Prince two
years older a midfielder playing for
Ghana the two were Berlin natives they
both started out young kicking their
first footballs around at this
playground in the heart of the city
lastly three others i'm in KP when Kevin
could do a trick that Jerome couldn't do
Jerome would go away in practice and he
wouldn't come back until he'd mastered
the trick when I didn't click amal
quanta both still regularly visit the
district where they grew up and they
remain close personally despite the
professional rivalry Jerome plays for
the German champion side Bayern Munich
Kevin for Schalke but they began their
professional careers together in Berlin
not by Kevin location be recognized at
an early age that Kevin was
exceptionally good Jerome was different
he actually played as a striker earlier
Oh Duma always wanting the ball playing
center forward and on the wing that's
helped him a lot in his current position
as defender for the annoyed he gets
pushed in my sights for tidying up the
pair were involved in a brotherly duel
at the last world cup in south africa
germany beat ghana one nil much to the
delight of jerome boateng
you